look at my body in stances and then I
just move in my shoulder at the
beginning have your internal work
actually be an external hello what my
body is going to move see my body like
that on the late shift and then my body
turn and there's the app you can as a
visual pelvic floor angle the body
weight shift
try to use this little arm movement and
moving through space independently of
your time reduced reduced Gohan mood
because your spine and pelvis are
shifting
when you get better than all that is
internal all that internally and it'll
work and it looks to you like it's the
shoulder but it it feels to him like
it's not so do we gain big big clientele
this movement let's emphasize that had
expressed here the intention point and
you are going to figure out how to free
yourself from it so obviously you can
see that there is this kind of ego in
unique you'll see that
but you have to happen at a certain ring
so if you're here and you try to do this
you're going to get step two on his
thumb getting stuff I don't know what
your raise is going to be and it should
be effortless like that and his knife it
should roll right into my trap that has
the spaces knife-edge need for me that's
where I'm going to move if I just want
to check them down then this hand can do
what you got to do it is doing its own
thing but since you're going for cutting
a comment it's actually this hand that's
controlling the technique
we can ignore that ending for a little
bit and just see if you get there
okay you go I'm out breath you don't
have her hand needed to make a whole lot
more rotation so you're going to use
your contact point to get that handle
not grab use the contact point pressure
you're fine you're fine okay pressure
plus pressure the right time it's what
roles that you see that and I get in
place so it's about sensitivity see you
guys are just doing your own thing like
usual okay no enter into this
relationship
boom hit it to go
they should have to go around that
energy you'll find
what you know when you guys feel the
resistance what do you think you push
back honestly that's what's happening
here
no just keep going around and keep going
around it keep going around it can you
get it I you can I would not recommend
tensing up when your elbow is getting
tweaked so much there you go all right
so here right now
my first projection right and it got is
balance and now I get you guys are
thinking that you've got no fourth leg
over here and so that you're just going
to shove that oval down by half
okay what is he very athletic and he
loses playin teenis
or what if he's very strongly in
Overtown which is very probable so your
art will again work only for slower
weaker people that's not really should
be training for so let's just look at
what happens to his shoulder when you
turn his hand now now he is has the
angle cancellation right cause here at
didn't he wanted to grab underneath we
could see wanted to step in he could but
wants to go back once you start dropping
his shoulder right you cancel all that
out so the technique is not this and
then I shove him down
the technique is on continue with the
Kazushi right there and I follow a guy
who's falling down don't throw him down
he's falling down and I'm following this
and that only happens if you're on the
knife edge of the hat anywhere else it
doesn't - initially you have to take his
knife edge to turn
so I want you to do the same technique
but this time you're going to watch what
happens to his shoulder watch what
happens to you you're trying to turn his
shoulder down it's a kind of naturalness
to what they're doing there's a symmetry
there the relationship between the two
it was not going like this and what's
not changing it with angle so this
movement that you're doing here this
movement the inverse spiral at the top
very important okay and then here's that
exchange very important meaning there
master key movement so he chose the
stripes in my head there's your inward
spiral just I'm an adversary okay it's
the beginning movie that you come around
on the carotid you use it everywhere
it's also one of the best ways of
cultivating your power
so this this movement here there this
move around here is the same things that
you could use it on strikes we've done
in the floor where I've hidden from the
bathroom hitting from this watch hitting
this way home and we doing the handgun
tip class we use it to cut with the
front side to remember okay so you guys
have you see that how's that ever going
to be a master to you but it's also not
a good comfort at home so when I catch
this side of him like that then I got to
shove them down you see so you gonna be
stronger than him and then you picturing
you know like that's going to work but
he has a lot of leverage right now you
think nothing turned up it's not going
to happen or I dip these down and I'm
just holding like this this is what
takes away his his leverage so do the
same arm straightening move that's not
gonna work beeping so a lot of your like
this and then they bend their arm for
you and then you you're picturing this
twisting movement and you know almost
like a Tamura but it's a
misunderstanding of the two more - it's
a misunderstanding cutter that's on it
people do not just give up like you can
like your guru kami
so you're like this and then people it
takes bridge little strength for someone
to do the very first rule you do when
you get here which is you know extension
practice recession time you can will
extend all Aikido moves actually expect
resistance from two gay we just live in
a culture of like you know we're who
kids just at Asajj Tony but and but
that's not here okay so what he has to
be expected to want to push up with that
hand watch her extended speak and so if
you pay attention to his body and push
up with his him really hard
it's just beating the pin isn't it huh
you think when you when he now extends
his arm like this it does not see the
pin the Energy's not going down from his
energy coming up to understand so so
much so let's say let's say I didn't
want to you know I don't know I and I
got like why I like the middle of the
hand I'm trying to do it right that's
where the other technique comes in from
kill see so here's here seong-chil and
he games he tries to extend his arm go
ahead you can extend his arm but if I
have a bad song kill and need extend
this off
so you're trying to learn this universal
movement you're trying to get the night
in here stuff happens right if you
feel like you're you don't have it so
that his resistance is feeding the pan
they look you just come underneath and
you'll have some kill where you're now
on top of the hand now I'm going to try
for you technique I didn't quite get it
I'm just going to come underneath and
get myself on top in the spectator with
ah that's an interesting song choke
nobody was it it's an adaptation to a
messed up coming up on your mess no me
while I'm trying for it
yeah I'm low on the risk you see that
that's not going to happen someone come
up underneath this is what I have
is that I love you see that so you come
up underneath put it on your chest
and you have the same okay try you have
to have your transition smoothly so here
I got it I'll try to mess up so it has
to be smooth tension free mess up again
for the my hand has to move out of the
way car my hands going to move out of
the way and we'll replace it with my
check out of the way and end up on life
out of the way on my teeth now I'm
passing it just like this first part
right look I'm passing it from his grip
to my forearm but now I'm going to tap
it from mine my pin hit alarm to my
chest
[Music]
boom and I'm going to put it on my check
on my chest it electic see the
difference you up he goes down and I
change my tactic because I know I'm not
going to have it I've put it on my chest
it goes on my chest you think ok let's
just just like sensing right I not have
contact with the court you don't you're
dreaming if you think you're going to
come up here and catch that man in the
same way in fencing you come off the
sword here you just your chance to find
it and go way down ok so I keep in
contact we call that control maintenance
right right right ok so when I moved to
the chest one and I come in here like
this this pan cannot open up and I go
that's not going to happen
he has to stay within the chalk he has
to stay within the trap so here I take
it off
[Music]
one once you felt that you didn't get it
this hand is not going to do what you
think it's going to do so you need to
change your tactics you see it's not on
the elbow oil boom it's going here so I
am keeping contact if I am here contact
but now I bring it to my chest it stays
on my chest boom boom
bring it to your chest it stays on my
chest I don't open it up and try to find
it one more time on my chest so this is
why I open it this way not this one open
it this way okay let's do this movement
here this body movement
remember suspended drills need to just
do
here it is directly right then okay so
now I'm coming to here and why do you
not like this you're doing the same
movement again somebody long time ago
and a bunch of people after that person
thought you know what this movement is
pretty important okay they don't seem
try to find it
[Music]
okay whatever you got there okay the
rest of it remains the same it's the
same warm pin same thing with the chemo
it's the same one okay and again
tactically you would look at it as
either of his a break or dislocation
it's not really attend trainee was it's
a coke ute hole it generates kokyoku
because of the way that it's going to
use internal projection in a dynamic
tension clinging aspect okay
so meaning if I if I sit here long
enough he just like in the Kimura
counter he's going to pin this shoulder
and move everything else you see this is
just no way out so you would have to
like some of the things we do is we get
the other arm off you can put your knees
on so he can't roll over right okay so
think of it more coke usual coupe so I
need to engage my Center my core and I
have to stop using my shoulders and my
biceps right okay so how do I do that
let's get there please
so my you kids going to chill out and if
I am at this angle which is popular it's
something magic about this 45 there's
I'm going to have to use my biceps to
get this thing
okay and even if I have the knife this
year though this is not the angle at
which he would feed back into the law
this is the angle that he would extend
me so let's just start with this
perpendicular angle see it's fine and my
knees are perpendicular to the spine if
I'm here and I don't have control of
this knife edge again you're going to
end up having to use your bicep to
correct it's a very inefficient it's
definitely not coachable if I have is
not bench but his elbow is to the foot
side of my third line again his
resistance does not feed the lock then
does not generate the dynamic tension
that I'm using as a training tool so
same thing if this elbow is all my
centerline his elbow has to be in front
of my centerline does everyone
understand that okay and I've used this
hand to keep it there keep it there hold
myself to make sure I'm not using my
biceps and then I push from my Center
that means my my center of gravity
actually moves forward takes his elbow
towards his head not in a rotational way
it I'm going straight in you see that
same thing nothing changes if I'm in
Tucson kill grip nothing changes elbows
brought push.txt let's go anything that
you had to turn that meant that your
your mechanical structure was not
feeding the tin in the first place
so if I have in lefthand and I was doing
this motion you see that the turn that
man scepter left hand was over here if
their left hand is over here you're not
getting there okay
do you understand that much so I don't
care how many years you've done it that
way that's why we're doing the class
that way does not work that way does not
train so everything has to go into that
I don't have to ever be like this so
that I have to go like that so be strong
not going to work okay so we'll just
have the guy lie down and then you get
yourself in position so that it's
already there and then you just push
push push okay beside the training
aspect and I really think you should
let's just look at this kind of stuff
okay
if I start taking hands away so let's
take this one and he'll extend his arm
and now I'm not going to get it let's
take this one away I'm not going to get
it
this becomes limbed attended easy if I
have the other one and I'm here like
this so that's consistent with my
tactical architecture it's built upon
redundant systems so I could take many
of them away and still get it on the
other one I couldn't so I put the arm
where where it's going to be and you can
see that you can take the art you can
take the arms to it it's still going to
do its thing you can take all the arms
away
okay why would that be important because
people fight do you understand that's
why you have redundant systems things
fail so you need something in case of
sale okay